laughs stop
Louis I'm your uncle Jonathan are you
wearing a robe it's a kimono here we are
home sweet home
you're Luis I presume how was your trip
this old hag is my neighbor I'm relieved
to see you didn't inherit your uncle's
freakishly oversized head my God did
that withered purple skeleton just speak
you'll see it's quite different here
have a look around you're perfectly safe
that's safe as long as it's fed do you
know what a warlock is Lois a boy which
I think they're a little more than boy
widgets are you saying that your luck
please teach me please please okay have
it your way
I can give you the right books teach you
the right spells but that last one for
Saturday that's up to you
I don't want the creepy little runt sink
I wanted lucky shot
you've told Lois everything not
everything this house used to be owned
by another warlock
he's very wicked very powerful he left a
hidden clock in the walls we don't know
what it does except something horrible
three gums last time it was for what
happens when it gets down to one nothing
good that's for certain
we have to destroy the clock
so creepy you can't do this alone I can
help you
once these real magic I'll show you
shall we die he Punky's
Oh
you